[Music]
foreign
logan yuri i've been waiting so long for
this conversation
yay well i'm really happy to be here and
it's nice to reconnect after all those
years
so many years so we worked together at
dan royale's irrational labs you were
with google back then i was interning
in behavioral economics let's just start
there because
and then i have to run to this
relationship thing that you're doing and
your ted talk experience but let's start
with behavioral economics
how did you get to behavioral economics
and what were you doing there
yeah so i studied psychology at harvard
and i had a secondary
in women and gender studies so i was
super interested in
all of the different things that affect
how we think
and when i was at google i heard that
dan ariely was there
and i had the opportunity to work with
him on a project
and he was working internally on this
team called the irrational lab
and i was part of a marketing rotational
program so that meant
you started as an associate product
marketing manager you did
an assignment for a year and then after
a year you got
seven minutes literally seven minutes
with the cmo of google
and you can ask her questions or get her
advice on what to do for your second
rotation
me i prepped for many hours and i gave
her this seven minute pitch
on why i should be allowed to work with
dan ariely and the irrational lab team
and she liked it and she created the
head count for it and after that
i joined the team and then i later led
the team within google
wow okay so irrational labs give me two
three sentences what was it about
what what were some of the things that
were happening that that are interesting
so irrational labs what i loved about it
was that it takes this very academic
field
of behavioral economics which you know
but for your viewers
is the science of how we make decisions
and
the key idea behind behavioral economics
is we're not rational
we're irrational we often make these
mistakes in our decision making
but luckily we make them in these
predictable ways so if you can
understand
okay people have something called the
planning fallacy
no matter how long you think something's
going to take to get a project done
it'll probably take longer we always
underestimate it because we don't think
about the things that come up
so there's these very common mistakes
that we make in decision making
and if you understand those mistakes you
can help people avoid them
so we worked across different teams at
google i think we worked with over
52 teams and we would each one of them
say
okay what do you want the users to do um
what's happening now what are the
cognitive biases that maybe are causing
that and then how can we redesign
whether it's the product or the online
flow
so that the user will actually take the
intended action
yeah i mean it's like it's an art it's
not a it's on one hand it's a science
you know there's a bunch of academic
studies mainly
through dana reality and canaan and
verskin
all those amazing academics but at the
end but now dan is saying okay now let's
see how this can be translated
into the tech world and actual consumer
behavior and i can talk about behavioral
economics with you for hours
but what's really special here is you
branched off from there
into another field in psychology talk to
me about that
divergent yeah so while i was doing the
irrational acting and just
learning so much about behavioral
economics and just loving the chance to
do applied behavioral economics i also
was single and i was on the dating apps
and i was on hinge and i was on tinder
and coffee meets bagel and i was just
trying to figure out like what is
happening in love
and i saw that all around me lots of
people had the same questions
yeah i started this series called talks
of google modern romance
where i would bring in experts from
around the world to talk to us about
love
and the videos became pretty popular
within google it was pretty popular and
i was like okay
this is a thing people need to know
about love and the changing
way that we're dating and that kind of
turned into a bigger project where i
left google i went to airbnb i then left
airbnb
and finally i said i'm going to do this
full-time and now for the last
three years i've been working full-time
on applying
lessons from research and lessons from
behavioral economics to dating
to helping people find love okay so
before we go into your into the ted also
experience
talk to me about love what are some of
the things that you found
out about love well i want to know
everything yeah but
but tell me you know some two or three
things that i might not
be thinking of in the greater spectrum
of what is love and what is
relationships
in 21st century yeah so um
one of the big things that comes up in
the research is paradox of choice
i'm sure you've heard that term but the
idea there is that
we think that more options are better
and we always
choose to have more options but
oftentimes too many choices can be
really overwhelming and either leads us
feeling full of regret or making no
decision at all so dating today truly is
harder than ever before because of all
the options
and another thing that i think about is
how people are making the decision about
who to date
and who to settle down with and should i
get married and i like to think that
relationships are a series of decisions
at each decision point you could make
mistakes because of these cognitive
biases so if you understand what those
are you can help avoid them
right for example uh there's something
called maximizer satisficer framework
some people
say i need to look at every single
option and figure out the perfect one
and then i can make my choice and other
people say
i have a set standard and as soon as i
find something that meets that
i'll accept it and those people are
called satisficers and when you're a
maximizer and you're dating
it can be really hard to find someone
because you're always
looking for the for the next thing the
the perfect thing so
how can you avoid being a maximizer and
date more like a satisficer
that's that's so fascinating you know
one of the things that i've been
pondering is
you know i can't help but but realize
that our whole
culture is shifting over the last 100
years or so where you know 100 years ago
you
you had when you you got married i don't
know 18 to 20
or maybe even before that and then you
had a career in a certain field
you grow all together you have children
etc today
you know i'm looking at myself and my
friends we're going to go through
several careers we're going to move
around the world we're going to you know
change our perspective on different
things is
what i mean is there any some is there
some thought of how relationships
are starting to form in this new world
are they the same as before
yeah relationships are definitely
changing for a lot of the reasons you
mentioned
so one of the key things that i'll point
out from what you said is people are
getting much
married much later so there's an idea
that
relationships used to be a startup
two people come together early in their
lives and they
come together and they create a
relationship and now
marriages are more like a merger two
people who are fully formed
come together later in life when they
each have their independent identities
their personalities their habits
and they're now forming a union and as
i'm sure you can imagine
a merger is in some ways more
complicated than a startup
i was just about to say that in the tech
world you know mergers
are not usually they don't work even
if all signs point to go to yes yeah
there's
there's some internal conflict that
somehow arises
absolutely so yeah so that was when you
do
that yeah people get married later some
of the other changes um
you know you used to get married to the
person that your family recommended that
was through a matchmaker or your parents
that was
whether your plot of land was next to
the other person's plot of land
who offered the most camels for your
daughter's hand in marriage the gallery
all these things that's totally
different now
it's the same amount of work in fact
it's more but it falls on us
so we have a lot more pressure to get
this decision right we have a lot more
choices to make
to to choose from and i think that
if you're getting married at 30 when
your personality is a lot more defined
and you have a lot more preferences
likes and dislikes it can be harder to
find a person
who feels like the right fit interesting
okay so
so within the relationship spectrum
you're also very
very heavily involved in breakups and
and
actually you know actively on facebook
and social media you're helping
friends go through go through difficult
situations of their own
talk a little bit about that how did you
even get started with this
and and what are some common themes that
you can that you can now see
yeah thank you for asking me about
breakups i feel like i don't get asked
about it a lot but it is really a
passion point of mine
one reason i can fashion point of view
is okay watch out
yeah one reason i care about it so much
is i think if my goal is to help people
get into happy and healthy relationships
or epic relationships one of the best
ways to do that is by helping them get
out of mediocre or bad relationships
which is often so hard to do
right yeah absolutely so uh some of the
things i've done in the area of breakups
i do break up consulting
so people come to me and say i need to
decide if i should break up with this
person
we go through the pros and cons i
learned about their history i learned
about their patterns
are they somebody who's always breaking
up with people are they someone who's
always saying relationships too long
we work through that and then if they
decide that that's the right decision
for them
then i help them actually plan out when
are you going to have the conversation
what are you going to say
what are you going to do immediately
afterwards what are you going to do
three weeks later and we really just
create
a goal setting plan to help them pull
this off
so you know it's sort of a combination
of it's it's not really therapy or
analysis
it's like a friend a mentor and a
therapist all the same time
yeah i mean i think that that's ideally
what a really good coach is and i think
coach okay yeah yeah not i mean not to
be in pitching mode but i think that's
where the behavioral economics comes in
it's saying like yes one of the key
ideas in behavioral economics is
awareness is not enough
if you know that cookies are bad for you
it doesn't stop you from eating cookies
you need to actually create an
environment and have a plan that helps
you
stop eating cookies and in this way it's
knowing you want to break up with
someone is not enough you need a plan to
actually go
and have that conversation deal with the
repercussions
go through the decoupling process all of
that so what are the common pitfalls
that people face
in breaking up because i'm sure that
over time you can see some commonalities
in human behavior that are not allowing
us to
to sort of maximize our potential for
happiness yeah so my
philosophy on breakups and this is not
all people but many people fall into one
of two categories being a ditcher or a
hitcher
and these are terms i came up with to
describe ditchers are people that enter
into relationships
at around the three to six month mark
they say you know
she's not exactly right for me and i
have to be honest with myself and they
come up with reasons to leave and they
always ditch a relationship before
giving it a chance
and a picture is someone who gets into
these serious
long-term relationships and often stays
too long
past their expiration point and has
trouble breaking it off
and there's lots of interesting reasons
why both of these people do what they do
but in my work i try to help ditchers
stay longer
to realize that actually every
relationship has problems
um you need to give something a chance
you need to let it develop you need to
mature
you need to get in your reps in terms of
learning how to be in a relationship
and with uh hitchers i have
sometimes i tell them you know this is a
great relationship it's going through a
little bad spot and you should stay or
sometimes i say
i think you've been in this relationship
too long and you need to get out of it
and i'll help you do that
and i'm sure i mean it is difficult
because you are getting one side of the
story right you're getting
one perspective and you have this whole
other life that's
maybe even experiencing the relationship
in a different way
so where's the line with that and how do
you how do you
balance that how do you mitigate that
that lack of information
you mean like i'm only hearing one
person's side of the story right
yeah i mean that's absolutely part of
the work and i kind of have to take
everything people say with the grain of
salt
and i also have to understand that you
know if they're going through a hard
moment i'm hearing the negative version
of the story i'm only hearing one
person's side of the story but
what i have tried to develop is a
skill around pattern development uh
sorry pattern recognition so
even if one person says something and i
realize it's only 50
of the story i can recognize that as oh
this is a similar pattern to what i saw
with these three other people
here's what they said here's what they
then did here's what happened and i can
use that pattern recognition to give
them good advice
even if i'm lacking some elements of the
story
amazing and then you're invited to the
stead residency in 2018
and given the the opportunity to do
something that
any entrepreneur in any profession could
only dream of being on the tenth stage
and giving
a professional talk what was it like
talk walk me through it yeah i mean ted
was a fantastic
opportunity when i remember when i was
applying for a job in 2017
they asked you know what are some of
your life goals and i said to give a ted
talk and to read a book that my parents
would then
or sorry to write a book that my parents
would then read which is also
in the world yeah in the last three
years i've been able to do
both of those things and the book will
come out next year so i feel really
excited about that and
i think that's a good lesson that even
if you don't always accomplish the
dreams that you set out
to accomplish at least just saying them
out loud and being audacious
gives you a greater chance of maybe
achieving them and so with ted
i was a resident in 2018 i was part of a
cohort of around 30 people
it's just so fun to be in new york be in
the new york office
have access to amazing people doing
things like photography exhibits
architecture um environmental financial
initiative and at the end as you said we
gave a ted talk and
it was just such a great experience and
it really helped launch
this phase of my life how long do you
prepare for a ted talk
so we really started i would say
probably week one or two
of the four-month residency thinking
about
what's the through line of your talk
who's your audience what do you want
people to say after they hear it and
i mean i probably went through 12 or 13
drafts because
i was still figuring out my the thesis
of my work while
also trying to give a talk so yeah it
was challenging but
it was really i mean i think creativity
really thrives when you have constraints
and
i had the constraint of having to
deliver a talk on june 1st of that year
wow that's just unbelievable and so so
what's next
so you've done you've written you're
writing the book you d you give it to
talk you're
a world expert on relationship and and
break up so what what what now
yeah so i'm finishing the final edits of
the book
and going back and forth with my
publisher on that
and the book will come out valentine's
day 2021
and definitely yeah i recently joined
hinge as their director of relationships
so mike you know my go we talked about
this that my my girlfriend and i we met
on hinge and
so we we always joke that we our
relationship is sponsored by hinge
yeah i love that and uh so many
of the weddings they go to now that
people met on hinge and it's
unbelievable
is this the future logan is this is this
where things are
moving towards i think the future is now
so there's research from michael
rosenfeld of stanford about how people
meet
and as of last year more people met
through dating apps than any other form
for the first time unbelievable so if
you know
30 years ago it was at a bar or in the
library or a coffee shop today
it's mostly on dating apps yeah wow
where does ar come into here and i'll
just pinch a picture that i was talking
uh i was talking with a friend a couple
days ago is it gonna be
that in the future you know it's an app
like kenji
we'll just have our smart glasses and
we'll be able to have dinner
as a date through an app and you know if
we don't like it then we can just you
know
swipe right swipe left and move on to
the next dinner i mean how is it going
to be
i haven't thought too much about dating
in ar but
i do feel like in this moment you know
you and i are recording this during
coronavirus we're both
sheltering in place there's been a huge
rise in video chat dating
and fascinating about that is people are
saying like i'm still
swiping on the apps and matching with
people i do want to get to know them
normally i would say
let's go for a walk let's get coffee i
can't do that now so people are using
video chats for that
and it's possible that even after
coronavirus
ends that people will basically have
this
half date or first date that happens
over video chat before deciding to meet
up in person
does that does that make it a little bit
more honest
because you know there is this whole
infatuation phase and the physical
attraction that can sometimes
mask you know when when people are not
emotionally
right for each other so is this sort of
a way to put the physical aspect aside
and see whether mentally and emotionally
we connect
yeah i think that there's pros and cons
so first of all i don't think that the
physical attractiveness piece goes away
i think you're still
evaluating the person over video chat to
decide if you're attracted to them and
it's probably
you know for better for worse a large
part of your decision
one thing i've heard that has actually
stuck with me is
a client of mine in the dating coaching
world who
you know usually sleeps with people
right away and physical
affection is something that she engages
with early on and
it's not i'm not judging her in any way
just like that's her pattern and now
because of coronavirus she's forced to
take a step back and move a lot slower
and she's noticing that her
relationships have been developing
in a deeper more vulnerable way so i
think
for some people being able to video chat
first helps them focus on
the emotional connection before deciding
what's our
sexual chemistry like that that's
fascinating i mean logan thank you so
much for for
taking the time to do this best of luck
with the book
and the ted talk and everything is just
it's it's amazing and i'm so happy that
we had the chance to work together
and you know what was it i think six
years ago unbelievable and it was such a
great time
and before we leave i am going to put
you on the spot one time
and i want you to tell me three words
that you would best describe yourself as
or that you wish somebody you wish other
people would describe you guys
okay great sure and also you know thank
you for having me on the show it's been
fun to watch where your career goes and
i hope
thank you okay three adjectives let's
see
um the first word that came to mind was
tenacious
okay i think you know just really
sticking two things
you know having that point in my career
where i was like all right i love this
dating and relationship stuff
let's see if i can turn it into a job
totally passionate i'm really passionate
about the work that i do i'm passionate
about people finding love
and my interest in this has not waned
you know since i was 18 and i started
being fascinated by relationships
and then third word that comes to mind
is friend
i cared so deeply about my friends i
think
friendship is my hobby i just want the
best for
all the friends in my life and i i
really spend a lot of time
just engaging with and supporting and
being supported by my friends
logan thank you so much yeah really
really amazing and i can't wait to read
the book on valentine's day of next year
thank you and thanks for thanking me
okay bye
you